imagine you have some kind of voice
within you they try to ask yourself am i
behaving morally or not that's voice
sometimes is asleep hi I'm Mamie
Rockwell for recent TV and I'm here at
the games for Change Conference at the
Tribeca Film Festival here with Dan
Ariely who is a behavioral economist at
Duke University and the author of the
recent book the honest truth about
dishonesty how we lie to everyone and
especially ourselves so it's lovely to
chat with you today Sam you um this by
the way might have been one of your
lives for today which we often do we
tell white lies to people it may or may
not be lovely to chat with you stay who
knows so tell me a little bit about this
contraption that you've built here this
is called a truth box and you built it
for the conference tell me how this
works so this is basically give you a
chance for confession so what we ask
people to go inside and to say to tell
about a lie that was meaningful in their
lives something that they've learned
from thought about and so on and we've
had some fantastic stories about people
doing all kinds of things and you know
we have this this belief that yes we're
honest and it's other people but but
having to face some of your own past and
some of the lies that you have told that
might have been very uncomfortable and
you can tell a story about this but why
was it interesting and so on it's
actually a very interesting process for
us as researchers and I think also
cleansing and useful for the people who
are participating in it everyone
considers themselves to be an honest
person but there is that underlying
conflict that people have between
telling the truth and then wanting to
cut corners and get ahead so which side
do you find usually wins out so so
here's the thing there's lots of ways to
lie and the odd thing is that we lie a
lot and we think of ourselves as good
people and here's a here's one study it
imagine two people come to a room they
don't know each other and you say
introduce yourself to the other person
talked about yourself for 10 minutes at
the end of the 10 minutes you put them
in different rooms and you say did you
lie
and everybody said me of course not then
they say luckily we taped everything
you've said let's play it back to you
sentence by sentence and tell us whether
each sentence is absolutely the truth or
not and at the end of this exercise
people admit to lying two to three times
in ten minutes and think about it in
social interactions do you really want
to tell people everything you think
about them do you really want to portray
yourself in the most objective way so
the reality is that we lie a lot and we
recognize it and much of it foe is for
social lubrication much of it is white
lies and but it sometimes also happens
in there in the workplace well I mean
you did mention in your book that not
everyone is like a Bernie Madoff not
everyone is gonna try and get you for
all you're worth but everyone tends to
lie a little bit and those lies
accumulate and they actually can be
quite destructive so what are some ways
that you suggest that we can mitigate
these lives we can actually decrease the
amount of cheating and lying in our own
lives and in the lives of others so
first of all it turns out that having
strict rules really helped imagine the
tax code being very gray or very clear
and I think about something like
alcoholic anonymous and they have a rule
that says no drinking whatsoever what
would happen if the rule was half a
glass a day max right the glasses will
become very big you would say I'm not
drinking today I'll drink twice tomorrow
there'll be all kinds of negotiations
and not because we want to cheat other
people is because we tell ourselves
stories that are convenient for us in
the short term the other thing is having
some moral reminders so we do lots of
experiments we tempt people to steal
money from us get them to do a little
test and then they gray themselves and
they get paid by how much they gray
themselves but we can find out if they
greater themselves extra positively
compared to what they did but if we do
experiments in which we ask people to
first try to recall the Ten Commandments
or swear on the Bible or all kinds of
things like that
cheating goes down dramatically
sometimes is eliminated so if you think
about it imagine you have some kind of
voice within you they tries to ask
yourself am i behaving morally or not
that voice sometimes is asleep allow you
to do all kinds of things but if you
just recited Ten Commandments talked
about morality and so on officer and you
behave better
of the things we find is a pattern we
call the what the hell effect and the
idea is yeah people people kind of kind
of cheat a little bit cheat a little bit
and at some point they switch and start
cheating all the time and and people
report on this in dieting so let's say
you have a strict diet and you start the
morning with a muffin you say today I'm
not a diet here I might as well enjoy it
and the logic is that we think of
ourselves in binary terms were either
good or bad now if you're 92% good you
can still think of yourself as a good
person but if you're 78% good is it
really worthwhile moving to 80 82
maybe not you might as well go all the
way and enjoy it so we did some
experiments with confession it's a non
Catholic a confession and we found that
confession really helps so the moment
you declare what you've done badly you
are able to start a new page and you can
think about the Truth and Reconciliation
Act in South Africa is opening a new
page how do you go from apartheid to
post apartheid there's no smooth
transition but if you stand there and
you say here's all the bad things we've
done and tomorrow we'll try to open a
new page this really helps and I think
we need to think about more mechanisms
for that and then the most important
thing is eliminating conflicts of
interest if you like a particular soccer
team and the referee is calling a call
against your team you can't help I think
of the referees evil vicious stupid
blind something like that because you
want to see things in a certain way so
what happened is that we have a
motivated cognition we're able to see we
have tremendous flexibility in how we
can see the world and if we have a
conflicts of interest we will see the
world in a very different way lobbying
turns out to be incredibly valuable now
why because people are cheap and what I
mean is that you can buy somebody a
sandwich in a drink and all of a sudden
they start seeing life from your
perspective do you find that there are
certain types of people who are more
honest than others so in that respect
I'd probably say that you know you've
got politicians up here who are
dishonest and perhaps nuns and firemen
down here do you see late lying as being
universal so so in general we find it to
be universal we've tried first of all we
tried many countries so we tried China
in Israel we tried Italy we tried
England of course we tried Canada the
Canadians always think they are better
they are not a
tried South Africa we tried Columbia we
tried many countries we don't find many
differences and we also don't find
difference with intelligence with
risk-taking the one thing we do find is
that creative people cheat more and
here's the story imagines it's all about
rationalization you want to look at
yourself in the mirror and feel good
about it you also want to benefit from
cheating and you cheat a little bit so
you can cheat and benefit from it but
still look on yourself in the mirror and
feel good about yourself it's all about
telling a story and if you're creative
you can tell by the stories which means
you can cheat a little bit more and
still feel good about yourself